une opération coup de poing menée dans
la plus grande discrétion à 5 heures du
matin le dépôt de carburant de
coignières a été bloqué par une
cinquantaine de personnes
un site stratégique qui alimente en
essence les yvelines mais aussi
plusieurs départements d'île de france
un blocage organisé conjointement par
plusieurs syndicats dont la cgt sud de
78 l'unef et la poste sans répond donc à
l'appel qui a été lancé par tous nos
camarades dans les raffineries a bien
sûr amplifier le mouvement et à
généraliser les grèves dans nos
entreprises mais aussi à soutenir et a
multiplié les blocages des dépôts en vue
justement de construire le rapport de
force pour obtenir le retrait de la loi
travail et la satisfaction de toutes les
revendications qui s'exprime dans tous
les secteurs aux chemins de fer comme
ailleurs ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
quand fos-sur-mer est fermé c'est celle
ci qui prend le relais et vice versa et
de fait vu que fos sur mer va être
ouverte aujourd'hui et bien on a décidé
de le fermer celle de coignières on
s'est mobilisé on se mobilise contre la
loi de travail et jusqu'au retrait on
sera présent impossible pour les camions
citernes de sortir distribuer du
carburant aux stations alentour ou de
rentrer pour s'approvisionner
un blocage sans tension mais la
situation pénalise également les
travailleurs de cette zone industrielle
plus ou moins solidaire de cette
initiative
sabra fois que j'ai bloqué comme ça mais
ça ne me dérange pas il faut réagir
il faut réagir je viens normalement le
plus normalement du monde
comme tous les matins et je suis bloqué
aucun accès je suis pénalisé
je reste pénalisée je suis a donc je
suis pris en otage non les soutiens dans
la bas côté mais après il faut pas
empêcher les autres de travailler quoi
après si tout le monde s'y met aussi
les syndicats ont bloqué le site jusqu'à
10 heures du matin la police présente
sur place n'a pas eu besoin d'employer
la force pour les évacuer la situation
est ensuite revenu à la normale mais des
actions de ce type pourrait se
renouveler prochainement si le
gouvernement ne recule pas sur le projet
de loi travail